history of the pineapple 1492
Christopher Columbus lands on the island
of Guadalupe for the first time ever a
Westerner sees a pineapple right you
look at it and it's kind of a royal
fruit it's got this stupid crown on its
head and he writes in his journal he
describes the taste of a pineapple they
take a shipload back to the Prince of
Spain one of them makes it that isn't
rotten and the prince is allowed to eat
it almost gets this sort of mythical
quality to it the British they start to
see it as this symbol of opulence wealth
they would parade pineapples around at
dinner on a platter and they would use
them over and over and over again you
could rent a pineapple this is the sort
of house in which you might be able to
see a pineapple castles had pineapple
statues on the top of them all of this
occurred because of the scarcity of a
pineapple it was £8,000 to get one
pineapple wow right it was a symbol of
privilege and opulence and wealth people
really looked up to this one object then
the French couple hundred years later
they invent green houses price drops no
one starts parading the pineapple around
anymore the scarcity of it was largely
determining the value of it